[Music]
[Music]
one question that people ask me is how
do i apply creativity to the
presentations
that i give and my
secret sauce
is to come up with a visual image that
anybody i don't care for the adult
whether you're a fifth grader or second
grader that you can grasp that concept
and here's my favorite one so every
single time you move your body there's
whole bunches of neurochemicals that are
released in your brain
and you've heard of these neurochemicals
dopamine noradrenaline
serotonin and so that's the fact but the
image that i give is that every single
time you move your body it's like giving
your brain a wonderful bubble bath of
neurochemicals that enrich your brain
that change that neurochemical milieu
and that is the image that everybody
that comes to my talks leaves with and
inspires them a little bit to move their
body more so can you come up with that
image that that playful fun but but
factually accurate image that conveys
your message that will be your secret
sauce too have you heard that the bees
aren't doing great
well i've been studying that and trying
to understand how their complex health
issues connect to a curious little
parasite that's in nearly every honeybee
colony worldwide it's called varroa
destructor by the way now
before i started this study we thought
that it was an open and shut case that
the parasite was sucking out the bee's
blood sort of like a tick on a puppy but
i thought something more strange might
be going on the the damage that it
caused just didn't seem like the damage
that would be caused by blood removal
the feeding process is super difficult
to see though so
i had this idea
i i fed different color glowing food to
the bees in their pollen and their sugar
water to color their organs specific
colors then when the parasite fed on the
bees
i could tell which organ it was eating
based on which color was in its
digestive system and it turns out that
they were eating the bee's liver by the
way
which is pretty weird um but
this kind of work is actually pretty fun
and it was definitely a place where
creativity was rewarded in biology